there are three new signs a russian
invasion could be imminent so what are
they
well the first main indicator has been
observed at a training camp in russian
occupied crimea known as the angerski
training area
growing activity has been identified
here in the last two months including
the appearance of light brown
rectangular tents and another structure
to the north a military analyst has said
this is likely to be a new field
hospital and this is seen as a
significant development because field
hospitals are of course designed to
treat wounded soldiers unless they're
being used during a military exercise
as we've heard in the past couple of
weeks the camp has also seen an influx
of military personnel 60 large tents
have appeared which sleep up to 20
soldiers each and to the south another
15 tents have been identified so far
this year
now faint rectangular indentations in
the snow near the hospital suggest a
number of tents have also been moved
the second significant development is at
novu zen a base 65 miles north west of
angerski also in crimea
new military tents have also appeared
alongside equipment that has been there
since last spring
now satellite images from there show the
difference from the end of december
where there's all this empty space
and it now looks like this with the
capacity to accommodate a significant
amount of more troops
now the third development concerns the
movement of equipment belonging to
rosgvardia a russian militarized
internal police force in the direction
of the ukrainian border responding is a
russian internal security force that's
equipped like a paramilitary force with
heavy equipment and with equipment for
inflicting mass casualties it's designed
not only to help the russian state
control its own citizenry but also to
keep control of occupied territories
when russia mounts an assault in another
country and that's why it's significant
that it's now being moved to join the
forces that are poised opposite the
ukrainian border because it gives russia
the capacity to hold territory that it
sees from ukraine as well as just attack
it
these same researchers have been
analyzing social media posts to track
their equipment moving in russia and
they've identified a truck moving south
from northwest russia with a gold emblem
of the security force on its side
russia's intentions remain unclear but
there is only a limited amount of
further escalation possible with experts
saying any final movements before an
invasion could come from the air